Jason suspects Windsor Grove now detain
wintergrove to have a dog van on the
hurry up please
we've got young people who are more
willing now to carry knives and think
they're justified in doing so for the
vast material of young people there
isn't a relationship with the police
there's a lack of trust in the police
yeah I've got a nice fun yeah so let's
not argue about it anymore right
where I come from it's new to hear that
someone's died sadly enough from a knife
this epidemic I will call for my mother
and my mother just said the Blues on the
floor he's not moving he's dead
[Music]
in South London the specialist antique
gang unit officers are responding to an
incident involving a knife colleague has
called for urgent assistance the officer
is struggling with two men who may be
linked to the knife incident another
suspect has run off believing there's a
possibility the two might have a weapon
the officers are taking no chances but
one of the men is determined not to be
handcuffed
this is a pretty violent end to what
should have been a routine stop and
search the arresting officer is clear
it's a situation that escalated because
of the reaction of the man he stopped
straightaway he's been telling me to F
off and whatnot and then he started to
push me and as money heats have arrived
he's still not complied I've threatened
him with CS fried he's still not
complied and that's unfortunately he's
got to that stage where it's escalated
just for the sake of the stop and search
just to find out about the knife after
questioning this man was ruled out as a
suspect in the knife incident and
released police say he'd never have been
arrested in the first place that he
simply been willing to speak to them
across the UK violence including knife
crime is on the rise but it's the
capital where the problem is most acute
with almost four and a half thousand
knife related incidents last year
already this year thirty people have
been stomped to death we have a lot of
information that is indicating to us
that it's almost become a trend and
we're doing a lot of research at the
moment in order to try and make sense of
what the statistics and what the
qualitative data and information is
actually telling us in order to come
back with a feasible plan that can have
a long-term impact it may be
generational it's not going to be a
quick fix we are primarily an
enforcement agency and enforcement is
what we do but by working cohesively
with our communities with education and
health and other non statutory and
statutory organizations that will be the
way forward officers a Notting Hill have
stopped a man they see as a known gang
member he was stabbed last year and
police intelligence reports see he now
regularly carries a weapon we're
actively targeting what we call habitual
knife carriers and that we'll be using
an Achilles heel approach any kind of
crime that they might have been involved
in in order to get them off the streets
in order to seize their weapons and that
is proving to be very effective under
the banner of operation sector police
found nothing during this search but
just two days later the man was stopped
again officers say they found him
carrying a loaded handgun he's now in
custody
as government police and community
leaders search for ways to combat knife
crime the human toll continues to grow
it's a year since 20 year old Lewis
Alvin was stabbed to death in South
London a murder which is still unsolved
the day I heard about I got a call from
my brother I was literally in Notting
Hill you know and I drive my van I was
towards the end of the afternoon maybe
about four o'clock and I got a call from
Byron saying you know Louis yeah she's
dead yeah and you know my whole body
just it just went numb it's finally
knowing song could commit such an
offense such an act of violence but yet
no one's been caught no and this is just
in one case these cases are popping up
everywhere nowadays in Kensington
officers are responding to reports a man
has threatened a group of people with a
knife in a nearby park
they've stopped this man who's admitted
being involved in an argument with the
group but officers told me he denies he
threatened them with a knife police
believe the weapon may have been dumped
elsewhere but searchers fail to find
anything across the capital though the
latest drive against knife violence has
taken hundreds of weapons off the
streets here at Scotland Yard they've
gathered together around a hundred
knives for us these are just a small
fraction of the weapons that have been
seized in recent weeks and they range
well just from ordinary kitchen knives
to some more decorative weapons but
police say there could be no excuse no
legitimate excuse for carrying any of
these weapons on the streets
it's the early hours of the morning in
South London and the Lambeth gang unit
have stopped to speak to this man who
was sitting in his parked car on a quiet
street he's insisting he's done nothing
wrong and that he's being targeted
because of the color of his skin the man
is still insisting this stop and search
is racially motivated and you have got a
knife on you so let's not argue about it
anymore right
Scotland Yard commanders are more than
aware of the sensitivities around stop
and search but they believe it is a
valuable tactic in some knife crime
hotspots it will be increased stop and
search is working well in London is
really on a reduction overall but there
are certain barriers where it is used
more effectively and there needs to be
more of it in order to deal with the
with the issue that they're facing
around knife crime in particular but
look stop and search is not the only
response
Jamie Molly runs a project in North
London helping provide opportunities for
young people she believes stop and
search is ultimately counterproductive
it is an intergenerational issue stop
the search didn't just pop up five years
ago this has been an issue for
particular communities especially the
black community for decades and so
without we can't take out of context a
police officer may say that they're not
intentionally stopping young black
people but this is the context that
we've got this is the history that we've
got it cannot be detached from that
among this group of teenagers who've
been stopped in South London are some as
young as 14
not yours or why have you got about a
fart when you back officers clean the
boys are linked to a local gang and just
two days earlier were suspected of
committing a burglary armed with a knife
when police stopped the group then they
recovered this combat knife in Brixton
this boxing gym is one place where
youngsters and the police interact in a
very positive way off-duty officers
among those acting as coaches also
offering advice and guidance the reason
I actually came to this place is because
of when I ran with my head teacher for
my school found out and then so the
police took it off me and then they did
the interview and then they told me
instead of doing all of the like trouble
with the knife crime to come to the gym
until Watson
hey I would give it a try and then I
came and I enjoyed it either cos one of
the volunteers at the gym a project set
up in memory of his friend Dwayne
Simpson
one of many victims of knife crime in
this part of South London I know
probably about 20 people that's been
stud right from my state alone at least
7 of them's been taken away
I think it's fashion to be fair majority
um I'll say yeah I don't know 80 are 10
of them do out there they don't really
need to walk around with a my when I was
growing up you won't even think of
walking around with a knife but you
won't really need it Lewis he'll wounds
brothers are also now actively involved
in helping steer youngsters away from
knife crime they need role models and
not just movie stars and athletes he
needs practical role models
whether you're black white orange gray
there's positive people out there I can
help share their story and experience
with you so that you don't have to make
those kind of decisions are gonna set
your future ultimately tackling knife
crime will be as much a community effort
as it is a policing one Jason suspects
Windsor Grove but while people continue
to fall victim to knife crime the police
make no apologies for going after those
they suspect of carrying weapons
detainment arrives with a dog van on the
hurry up place more than 300 knives have
been taken off London streets in recent
weeks many seized in stop and search
operations it remains a controversial
tactic but one police believe is vital
in helping combat the shocking rise in
knife attacks it is a fact that people
who carry knives are more likely to have
them used on them themselves it's a
knife it would normally have a Stanley
blade in it so it was I think Camberwell
direction by the sounds of it I think
it's time that people wake up to this
and save adults on burying kids whereas
the normies kids are buried adults but
now it's just everything says backwards
[Music]